welcome everyone this is rob sanders
from
simply learn and today we're going to
talk about
google display network so thanks for
joining and let's get started
so i want you to imagine having the
world at your fingertips especially when
it comes to advertising imagine
having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising
so just imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to
any website in the world can you imagine
that
well imagine having that entirety at
your fingertips the entire world
so it's not really an imagination so no
need to imagine
anymore because google ads
has come to the rescue so no need to
imagine the world
is at your fingertips and why is it at
your fingertips because
of google and specifically google
display
network okay so we're gonna talk about
what the google display network is so
let's start out
by asking the question or answering the
question what is the google display
network so
google has two networks basically one
the search network
one the display network so you as an
advertiser
if you want to advertise on google you
have a choice
can i go with google search or can i go
with the display network
well the search network is for google
search only so if you want to advertise
when somebody types in a keyword query
and you want your ad to show up
that's the search network so it looks
something like this somebody types in a
keyword
data science and lo and behold ads show
up and here you can see the first ad
from simply learn
why did that ad show up because simply
learn was bidding on the keyword
data science and so that's how the
search network works
you bid on keywords somebody types on
those keywords and your ads show
up in the search engine results at the
top above organic listings
so that's the search network and it just
simply comprises of
ads that respond to what people are
querying okay the display network is a
little bit different
so that's the search network today we're
going to talk about
the display network okay the display
network is a little bit different so
imagine you're on the lookout for a new
shoe on amazon as an example
but you don't have end up buying the
shoe you're looking at shoes
you don't buy it well you might have
noticed
in the past you've done something like
that whether it be shoes or shirts or
coats
or belts or cars or radios or
headphones or phones it doesn't really
matter
you might have been looking at something
and then notice
an ad show it might have been exactly
that same product or might have been
something
similar to the product you were looking
at but on the same website
so why does that happen well it happens
because
google's display network specifically
remarketing which we'll talk about
so on google's display network you have
the option to advertise that somebody's
been on your website
so that's one of the powers and one of
the features of google's display
network and that's remarketing or
retargeting somebody that's looked at
your product
so let's take a little bit of a deeper
dive into
how the display network works so if
you're a customer
you go to a website and you leave that
website
again from a remarketing perspective
your product can appear on another site
okay so that's remarketing so you can
retarget that person who's been to your
site so that's
again one great example of how to use
display network
in google terms we call it remarketing
and again somebody goes to your website
they leave in this example not buying
something
it could be a technology company where
we want somebody to watch a video or
download
a pdf okay whatever they do that
that you want them to do but they don't
actually do it then you can go back and
retarget
them so if they actually go to a page
and look at your product but don't buy
that product then you have the
opportunity
to advertise to them again so the whole
idea is if you advertise them again
wow that person can say okay i remember
that i was in
still interested in that product let me
go back and purchase that product so
they go back to the site
and make the purchase so that's again
the power of the display network you can
reach people who have been to your site
before
so let's take another look here so
retargeting
evolves around adding a piece of code or
pixel
on your website which uses browser
cookies to add website visitors to your
audience so
let me just summarize that for you so if
you want to use the display network
and you want to target people who've
been to your website well you need to
add a simple script
or pixel if you will to your website
that's all and so when somebody comes to
your website they're going to get
cookied and that cookie is stored in
their browser
and so that's an important piece of the
whole process because
that's how google determines who that
visitor is so without that
cookie then google won't know to show
their ad your ad to them again
so that's the first piece in all this so
when somebody does get cookie
they're going to be added to that
audience and so when we say
audience we mean you as an advertiser
defining who you want to retarget to
so in this example we're talking about
people who've looked at a product
and didn't purchase that could be a
whole audience in itself
people who look at a product and don't
purchase it could be everyone who comes
to your website it could be only return
users it could be only new users you
defund the audience but however you
define
that audience they're gonna get cookied
and placed on a list
and when they're placed in that list
they're gonna get shown the ad again
so past visitors will see your product
ads when they're browsing the web
watching videos on youtube going through
news sites and so on
so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're going to
be able to see your ad
because google's displayed network is
much more than just websites it's also
youtube
it's also news feeds it's also social
networking sites so there's a lot
involved with google's display network
so the network
involves several websites that are
partnering up with google
along with the likes of youtube along
with the likes on millions of other
websites
in fact these websites together tally up
to more than 2
million that encompasses more than 90 of
the internet so
you can imagine google's display network
is just made up of a bunch of websites
including youtube okay so you have the
opportunity to really reach somebody
that's been to your website before
so again if they're past visitors and
they looked at a product and they didn't
purchase it
you have an opportunity to really put
your ad in front of them
on a lot of different websites so that's
just an
intro about the display network
remarketing is just
one benefit but let's take a step back
so we dove into the deep end with
remarketing let's just separate out the
two again
just so you're clear on what the display
network is
versus the search network well let's go
some through some of the differences
so display network on the left search
network on the right
so the display network as we just
discussed
is great for retargeting people who have
been to your website
whether they're new users returning
users users who looked at a product
users who added a product to your cart
users who looked at a specific page
whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network
is usually for top of funnel why do we
say top of funnel because
users are actively searching for
something they're looking for a product
they're being active so they're going to
search and seeing
who has that product okay the display
network we know remarketing is a benefit
but
usually it's bottom of funnel like brand
awareness
so if nobody knows who your brand is
or what your brand is or what you have
to offer what your services are
then the display network remember made
up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display
bottom of funnel search network top of
funnel somebody actively looking for
something let's take a look at some
other differences here
so display network easier to advertise
products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again
if you have a new product you want to
get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least
they're going to know what the products
about on the search network on the other
hand
if somebody's looking for something like
a particular product that you're
offering
then they could type in a keyword that
describes that product
and wham your ad can appear at the top
okay remember top of funnel so products
and services usually fulfill a
particular requirement now
the display network can be used to
familiarize users
to your brand so again going back to
remarketing
somebody comes to your website they
really don't know who you are well
you can reach back out to them on the
display network with another ad
retargeting and that's how you get users
familiar with your brand
where on the search network users are
showing ads based on what they search
for
so it doesn't really matter if they know
your brand or not
hey if they're looking for something and
they're ready to buy
and you have that product at the right
price then the chances of them
converting are pretty good so you're at
the right place at the right time
where the display network's all about
familiarity retargeting to people with
your brand getting your brand out there
getting your product out there in front
of millions of people
now on the display network users are
shown these ads in over a million
different websites so
with the display network you have the
opportunity to kind of hone in and pick
and choose those websites
where on the search network users are
showing ads
in google apps and on the search engines
so you have the opportunity to place
your ads not just on
desktop search but also on mobile and
also
on apps whereas again the display
network is made up
of much more it's made up of websites
youtube apps etc okay the display
network
has a multitude of different formats
okay when we say different formats
we mean text ads image ads rich media
ads meaning ads that have some
functionality to it like movement
okay and then video ads where the search
network is
really only text ads and i say really
only text ads well you can
have image ads those are called shopping
ads but
mainly it's text ads where display
network you have an option between text
image rich media or video edit so you
can see the differences here really
there are big differences between the
two networks
where search you're just really
responding what somebody's looking for
they're really active and ready to go
display
hey you're trying to reach out to these
people you're trying to introduce them
to something
and in some cases with remarketing
you're reaching out to them again
okay you're trying to get them familiar
with your product and brand and you're
trying to do that
via video via rich media via a regular
image ad
via text ad so you're trying to do it in
a multitude of formats
so again bottom of funnel for display
top of funnel for search so that's an
intro
to the display network those are the
differences between
search and display now let's go through
the steps
of how to set up a campaign
in google ads using the display network
as our option so here i am i'm in google
ads
i'm in an account and i want to set up
a campaign on the display network so you
can see here if i'm in google ads i've
selected display campaigns i can already
see
i have some display network campaigns
set up in fact
they're all remarketing campaigns okay
so remarketing remember
is targeting somebody who fits a list
or description okay so it could be
somebody looking
at a particular product they get cookied
meaning that
text file is gonna sit on their browser
and then they're gonna see your ad
the next time they're on google's
display network wherever site they may
be
so we're reaching out to somebody who
fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display
campaign meaning a campaign on google's
display network we want to go to
campaigns and we want to click on the
plus button here
and we're just going to say new campaign
now we have the opportunity now
to pick and choose what our goal is for
that campaign and so
most of the time with display you're
going to choose brand awareness and
reach
okay so here you can see the campaign
types for brand awareness and reach
display and video usually when it comes
to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but
if you're just really trying to just
promote your brand
you may go with display because remember
you have the option to
get your ad in front of millions of
websites we're gonna choose brand
awareness and reach
okay and we're going to choose the
campaign type so here you have display
we want to run different kinds of ads or
we can run just video okay
we want to run if we're running video we
can reach and engage viewers on youtube
and across the web meaning other
websites okay let's choose display here
so we're gonna go ahead and just put our
website in there
so our businesses website and
when that loads up we're gonna have a
number of different options available to
us
so here we can name our campaign okay so
here you can see brand awareness and
reach
is the name of our campaign and for now
we're just going to protest
now we have the opportunity to choose
our location here we're going to choose
the united states
we have just like a search campaign we
also have languages and options so with
search you have locations and languages
same thing on display so we're going to
target english as our language
and what are we trying to do what are we
focusing on well
we want to get a product out there so
we're going to choose
impressions viewable impressions that's
really what we want to focus on we want
people to see our ad okay so an
impression
is the number of times somebody sees
your ad okay
so we have viewable impressions that's
what we want people to do we want them
to see our ad
and if you take a peek over here on the
right side you can see
your targetings reach so we can reach
over
10 billion plus in impressions meaning
that's a lot of eyeballs
the number of people looking at our ad
right now is over 10
billion plus okay so that just gives you
the scope and some idea of how
big google's display network is so just
like
search we could set a budget i'm just
gonna choose a hundred dollars for now
and i can
choose how to deliver that budget just
like on search
i have standard accelerated i can ask
google to speed up the spend or i could
just do regular standard which means
they're going to
spend my budget evenly over a period of
time over the
course of the day now remember with
display network
we have different options on ad types we
have text ads
rich media ads regular image ads and
video so we can rotate
our ads how we like so we could say hey
look i want to
run my best performing ads okay so that
means i want google to optimize
for me meaning if i have an ad that's
performing better than some others
then i'm going to let google run that
one more and that's the one i would
recommend but you do have other options
here
you can just have them rotate evenly you
can say hey
optimize for conversions but it's really
remember
our goal here for the display is to get
impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
in here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really our best option here
is prefer best performing ads we want
our best performing ads to run okay we
have an option to schedule them we have
an option to start
and okay and we have an option to set a
cap
how many times we want somebody to look
at that ad so we can limit how many
times our ad is shown to the same user
okay so we're going to let google
optimize how often your ads are shown
however we do have the option to set
that limit okay so we could set the
limit to
x times per day for the entire campaign
or it could be for a particular ad or ad
group okay so we could set the limit
ourselves and we can let google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions
okay and then we have the opportunity to
set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
network the ad group on display
is where your settings are going to be
your ads are going to be
located in your ad group and now the
important part we want to get to
audiences so
if we're remarketing we're going to
choose our audience
and if we're not remarketing we still
have the opportunity
to choose our audience so if i'm a tech
company and i just type in tech
then google is going to give me some
options here so here i can choose some
tech companies
technology client products new
inventions
etc or i can choose some ideas that
google has
in mind for audiences like they have an
in-market audience
so this is based on network systems and
services
network management so the bottom line is
google is giving me suggestions
on who i can target my ad to okay that's
what really what this is
choosing your audience now you don't
have to choose anything here in fact
you can just clear all and be done with
it now you can go down to
demographics now i could pick and choose
based on gender
i could pick and choose based on age
parental status
and household income really depending on
who you're advertising to that's really
what it comes down to it okay so you
have demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of google's
recommended audiences
or you can create your own audience and
we're going to talk about that here in a
minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so i'm saying hey these are the
demographics
and these are the audiences but if
you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you would on the search
network
and then you have the option to choose
your ad so that's
part of the campaign setup so when you
actually choose your ad
again you have different options image
ad
rich media ad video or text
once you choose your ad then you pretty
much have your campaign set up now we're
gonna
tweak it after we set it up but that's
pretty much the steps in terms of
setting up a display campaign
very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience
and choosing the ad type that's really
the main differences between
setting up a campaign on display and
setting up a campaign on search
the main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones
so we talked about remarketing to people
who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page
so if you're going to retarget the
people then as a best practice
i would set up the audience in google
analytics so
google analytics talks to google ads in
fact
you can link up the two in analytics so
regardless of whether you're
creating a display campaign or search
campaign
you want to link up analytics with
google ads
so you can see we've done that here okay
now that we've linked the two up
we could set up an audience in google
analytics
for use on a remarketing campaign
on google's display network so here you
can see i have audiences set up
if you want to just create a new
audience you can do that so if i click
new audience here
here i can choose choose returning users
or new users these are
audiences that google has set up by
default
i can create a new one if i want so i
could say hey i want to target
you know 18 to 24 year old males who
speak english for example and
who came from mobile so if i go here
technology i'm going to say including
mobile
so that could be my audience so anybody
who fits that description
of 18 to 24 year old coming to my
website
from mobile who speaks english i'm going
to retarget them
and you can go ahead and save this so if
i go ahead and click apply i'm going to
name my audience
18 24 year old male english
mobile one thing about remarketing on
the display network
is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live
so depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car
the funnel may be six months long if
they're buying a pair of shoes then the
funnel may be
seven days long maybe even shorter so
really depends on your business the
default is 30 days so
if you go with 30 days and that means
any 18 to 24 year old male
who speaks english and comes from mobile
is going to get cookied
and that cookie is going to live for 30
days so if i click next step
i can go ahead and publish it i can say
i want this to be available
in my google ads account so i'm going to
go ahead and pick my account
and it'll be available in that account
so i'll choose my account
and then go ahead and click publish so
now this audience list
is gonna be available for me to use
in my display campaign when i go to
choose my audience
so if i go back to google ads so google
ads and google analytics talk to one
another why because they're linked
and so now when i go to actually set up
my ad
group and i'm choosing remarketing i can
go ahead
and choose that audience list so for
example this campaign that's already set
up
i can go ahead and choose to set up
another ad group
with that particular audience list so if
i choose new ad group
and now i'm going to search for the
audience i just set up so here you go i
just did a search
and here's my audience i'm going to
select my audience
and i'm going to now use this audience
in my ad group for my remarketing
campaign
so now all i need to do is align the
right
ad with this audience so that's how
remarketing works
you choose your audience list you set up
your ads remember you have different ad
formats video rich media image and text
and the whole idea beyond remarketing is
you know who your audience is
you know what you want to say to them so
your ads
should really encompass that message
the message of what you want to say to
that particular group
in this case 18 to 24 year old male who
speak english
who came to your site from mobile so if
you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the display network to your
advantage
remember bottom of the funnel the goal
of our campaign
is just get our ad out there so that
people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go
to set up an ad group you don't have to
choose an audience to retarget to
you do have other options so if i look
at this ad group here
you can see i have image ads already set
up so where do i want these
image ads to appear so i do have options
available to me
in the display network so if i choose
keywords
then that means if i go ahead and add a
keyword
then what google is going to do is
contextually place my
image ad on a website that fits the
description
or matches that keyword so if i add
one or two or three keywords then what
google is going to do is going to look
at that keyword
and it's going to map a website on the
display network
using those keywords so that's keywords
now
you got to be careful here because it's
a broad way
of advertising meaning your ads could
appear on sites that you don't
necessarily
deem relevant to those keywords so
you're allowing google
to match the the website with the
keywords you choose
so that's choosing keywords audiences
again
audiences are there if you want to
retarget so if you're retargeting
you can set up your audience in
analytics in fact that's the best
practice
so again if i go back to analytics and i
go back to admin
under my property audiences i can go
ahead and choose my audience to be used
in google ads so that's using audiences
on a display campaign on google's
display network
when we're setting up our campaign we
had an option to choose demographics
so we can exclude a demographic if we
wanted to we can always go back and
exclude a demographic just by
removing them from the ad group notice
if we choose all demographics we can
actually then see
over a period of time in google ads how
many
people based on this particular age
group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw our ad but not only saw our ad
that wouldn't be impressions but clicked
on our ad and how much they spent
per click and how many conversions so
you have all that data available
to you in the display network okay
so that's demographics i can also use
topics
so i can take i can choose a particular
topic to advertise on
so if i choose topics i can choose a
particular keyword
find a particular topic or i can drill
down
on google's topic categories and
subcategories
so here you can see online communities
if i choose that one i can see there are
other
sub categories under online communities
okay i can choose the whole category of
science
or i can drill down to see what
subcategories are under science
so i can do that for any one of these
topic categories
and if i choose a category notice that's
where google is going to place my ad
whatever i select
again notice upper right here i can take
a sneak peek at
how many eyeballs google is expecting
to see my ad so here by choosing
astronomy and science
i have 310 million impressions that's
how many potential eyeballs
can look at my ad so if you're setting
up a display
network campaign you can choose keywords
you can choose demographics or you can
choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic
then your last option here is placements
so i can pick and choose a specific
placement if there's a particular
website that i want to advertise
on let's just say newyorktimes.com or
or latimes.com or webmd.com
remember there are over 2 million
websites on google's display
network so i can pick and choose
specifically
where i want my ads to be displayed now
when you're done choosing your audience
or your keywords
or your demographics your topics or your
specific placements
you can always then go to your
placements
and then click on where ads showed and
so
now over this particular time frame i'm
going to be able to see where my ads
have been shown
and so now i can see my ads have been
shown
by mobile apps and on particular
websites
now if you don't like any of the
particular websites that your ad is
showing on
you can always select it and you can
always
exclude it can exclude it from the ad
group or the campaign okay so that's how
you
manage where your ads are showing up on
google's display network again you can
go ahead and go to where ads are shown
under placements and over that
particular period of time
google is going to show you where your
ads have been shown and if you don't
like that
placement then you can always just
exclude it or
if you don't like the performance
meaning you're not getting many
impressions or you're not getting many
clicks or the click-through rate's very
low
you can go ahead and exclude it so this
is an opportunity for you
the advertiser to take control over
where your ads are shown
so in summary when you set up a display
campaign on google's display network
you have options if you're remarketing
you're going to choose your audience
going to choose your audience using a
list you created in google analytics if
you're on the display network
not remarketing you have the option you
can choose a keyword
and have google place your ad on a
website that fits the description of
that keyword
you could choose specific demographics
you can choose a topic
or subtopic category or you can choose a
specific placement okay those are
all the options available to you when
you run your ad
on google's display network now let's go
back and take a look at some of the
advantages
of the google display network so i just
went over
with you how to actually create a
campaign in an ad group
i actually went over how to set up a
marketing
campaign and set up a marketing list and
analytics and i
went over all the differences between
the search network and display but
let's really hone in on those advantages
here so
with the display network we can provide
advanced
targeting meaning i can particularly
point to
a specific website that i want to
advertise on so that's what i mean by
advanced targeting
or if i don't want to advertise to 18 to
24 year olds or 25 to 34 year olds i can
exclude them or
i can really pick and choose a specific
audience that i want to remarket to so
those are all
examples of advanced targeting and
that's all
done within analytics or google ads so
advanced targeting
enables you to target the people that
didn't engage with previous campaigns
and get in front of people with
look-alike audiences that can be created
based on the audience you usually
advertise to so
in other words we can really hone in and
pick and choose who we want to advertise
to
another advantage is relatively low
starting cost
so what we mean by low starting cost is
normally
on the search network you're bidding on
keywords and some keywords can be very
competitive
whereas on the display network you can
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose
where you want to advertise so you can
really advertise on websites to get a
lot of traffic
may not have a lot of competition and
therefore may not cost as much
so if you compare it to traditional
forms of advertising like tv or radio
display advertising reaching a large
broader audience
is a lot cheaper okay you can do
advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
advanced tracking
we're talking about again remarketing we
can really pick
and choose who we want to remarket to
and cookie them
and pick and choose how long they are
going to be cooking so we talk about
advanced tracking that's what we're
really talking about so we can also talk
about
how many times our ad is shown to
somebody we really can pick and choose
how many times we want somebody to
actually see our ad on a site
based on performance okay let's take a
look at some other advantages the
ability to advertise your
brand to a broader audience and google
has over two million websites
so we can pick and choose where really
where we want our ads to show up again
it could be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords
or it can be specific websites so we can
create
demand for our product and what we mean
by that
we can create really cool ads remember
rich media ads video ads these are all
engaging type of ads
those are ad types on the display
network we create engaging type of ads
it's going to appeal to somebody and
they're going to engage
so we have that opportunity just based
on the different ad types
of course increasing web traffic we
can't say that enough
if you're advertising on google's
display network you have the opportunity
to get your ad in front of millions of
people
getting from our ads in front of
millions of people we have the
opportunity
to get a lot of clicks and we do have
that wide range of formats
search network only has text ads here we
have text we have rich media we have
image we have video
so all these types of ad formats
allow us to really get our ads out there
in a number of different ways
again we're marketing our products and
services of the big
big big advantage using google's display
network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such
a key feature so if somebody comes to
our website and doesn't do it
we want them to do we can cookie them
and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailored to
that audience so those are all the
advantages
those are all the ways in which you
could take advantage of google's display
network so if you have anything to add
please
feel free to add a comment below this
video
we'd love to hear from you if you don't
good luck in setting up your google
display campaign
if you need any more information we're
here we're at simplylearn.com
thank you so much and i appreciate your
time look forward to seeing you in the
future
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here